et internationales se sont aussi cette
déclaration que martial du président
russe vladimir poutine met au défi les
occidentaux de défier la russie sur le
champ de bataille qu'ils essayent at il
dit selon lui son pays n'a je cite pas
encore commencé les choses sérieuses en
ukraine je vous propose d'écouter le
président russe
non chacun doit savoir que nous n'avons
pas encore commencé les choses sérieuses
micheline nationale
en même temps nous ne refusons pas les
négociations de paix mais ceux qui les
refusent doivent savoir que plus
longtemps ils refuseront plus il sera
difficile de négocier avec nous